All right. So last time, uh, we began,
or maybe two times ago,
we began a discussion of
various vocabulary and facts
you have to know about the
markets.
If you want to think about finance today,
we're going to deal mostly with the
most important one, the most basic one,
the yield curve. And last time
we introduced this word yield.
Now yield is an extremely
common expression in finance.
And it turns out not to be that,
um,
well defined often or that useful.
And but the word is so important is
when you so often that it's still hangs
around even when probably we
should use different concepts.
So remember the yield was an attempt to
look at an investment and without paying
any attention to the market or
anything outside the investment,
just looking at the investment itself,
try to assess,
give a number of quantifying how
attractive the assessment was attractive.
The investment was. So we said you could
apply that to a bond. It has cashflows,
you can apply it to a hedge fund that's
taking in money and paying out money.
And,
uh,
the formula we came up with said that
if the cash flows are given by c one c
two, the net cashflow CT over
the course of the period,
then uh, and its price is
some minus a, you know,
some price p zero, maybe it's a,
it's a negative cashflow. So see,
so some of these cash flows
might be negative and some
of them might be positive.
Then we should just look at the number.
Why such the discounting?
All these things at rate,
why gives you zero?
And the why that did that was what we
defined as the yield of the investment.
So we saw that that had some advantages.
For example, in a hedge fund,
if you just look at the rate of return
it makes on its money every year.
That doesn't take into account that
some years it's got a lot more money.
So if those were the years that lost
money in the ears when it hardly had any
money with the years that have made money,
I'm just taking the average,
the multiplicative average of all those
geometric average of all those yearly
rates of returns would give
a misleading figure. Well,
the yield also gives us
somewhat misleading figure
and I don't want to spend too
much time on, uh, why
it might be misleading.
Uh,
but I'll give you just an example.
Suppose that the cashflows happened
to be one minus four and three.
Now what's the yield to maturity?
Well, there are two of them.
You could have y equals zero because one
over one plus zero plus minus four over
one plus zero plus three of one plus zero
is just one minus four plus three that
equals zero. So the yield
to maturity of 0%, uh,
the yield of 0% makes this
have present value zero.
But also I could try y equals 200%.
And then I'd have why I put a plus to an
a plus two squared here and I had have
minus one plus one minus four thirds plus
one over three squared is one a three
over nine so it's plus one third.
So it'd be one minus four thirds
plus one third which also equal zero.
So as the yield to maturity,
the internal rate of return,
0% or 200% it's ambiguous.
So yield to maturity can't be
the right way of doing things.
To go back to the hedge fund example,
you know the hedge fund was a
taking in money, paying out money,
taking in more money,
paying out money and we
calculated the yield to maturity.
Well suppose that there was some period,
you know here at which point everyone
had taken all their money out so they
hedge fund wasn't actually do
anything for a bunch of years,
maybe for a long time.
And then it started up and you know,
took money in and paid
money out and stuff.
Well because the gap in time was
very long with nothing happening.
If you take a positive why the stuff
that happens in the second incarnation of
the fund is hardly going to be making
any difference because by that time it'll
all be discounted a lot.
So the yield,
the yield will depend to sensitively on,
uh,
stuff early rather than stuff
late. And so, uh, again,
you get into troubles yielding
just a yield to maturity.
So that can't be the right thing to do
even though people have done it for years.
So the word however lives on and there's
no getting rid of the word because it's
used in common vocabulary.
Now what would Irving Fisher say you
should do if you had to summarize how good
an investment was? What's
his lesson? What do you do?
Okay.
Uh,
an investment where there's no doubt
about what the cash flows are going to be.
What would he say you should do to
evaluate the attractiveness of it?
What's our lesson? Our main lesson
from Irving Fisher. What would he say?
Yes.
Well, let's say their
cashflows. So it's money,
money that you're going to
get coming in and out. Yeah.
He'd say deflate by inflation
and turn them into real, uh,
flows and then do what?
So just continue your answer. So
turn them into actual, you know,
potatoes every time you know
apples each time, you know,
the flight by inflation and
then do what with the numbers.
Okay.
This is a simple question.
You're thinking too hard. Yup.
Yes.
Okay. He'd say, just look at the
present value of all these things.
So of course to do that you'd have to
know what is the market rate of interest
with which to compute the present value.
So Fisher would say it's ridiculous
to evaluate how good an investment
opportunity is.
Just by looking at the cash flows,
you're throwing away too much information.
You know what the market is doing,
you know what the interest rates are,
use the market interest rates
and figure out what the uh,
present value of all the cashflows is.
So we're going to now do
that a bunch of times. Okay.
For the rest of the class and see,
see what that means.
So how do you know?
So we have to begin the first,
the two thirds of the class is
going to be spent on the question,
how do you know what the market
rates of interest are based?
So how do you know what the market rates
of interest or how could you find out
what I mean,
what the market rate of interest is.
What would you do to find it out?
Yeah.
And if you looked in the newspaper,
say could you find it in the newspapers,
what would you find in the newspapers?
Yep.
Okay.
Okay. And so how so? All right. So yes,
you try and look at riskless investments
like government bonds where there can't
be to fault. We least, that's
what they always used to say.
It can't be any default.
And an American, uh,
promise America has never
broken government never
broke a promise and they can
always print the money. So presumably
they don't have to break a promise.
So they're just promising money,
which they can print.
So why should they ever
break their promise?
So what would you find if you opened a
newspaper you would find for different
maturities? Um, used to be up to
30 years for different maturities,
you would find the,
the yield on the various bonds.
Okay.
So why would you find the yield? Well, uh,
the yield of various
government bonds of Gov bonds,
why do they quote the yield? Well,
that's just because, you know,
a hundred years ago people started
using the idea of yield and some of the
vocabulary as is, uh, been, uh, kept,
even though it's not the best way
of describing what's going on.
So for instance,
let's just look at some of the yield
curves you might've seen over the last 10
or nine years, almost 10
years since December, 2000.
You would see that in
December two thousands,
the yield on the one year bonds,
you know, or the, you know,
the short yields were, you know, these
are, this is a log scale. So this is,
you know, three, six, 12. Okay.
So the, the shortest bonds,
um, usually have lower yields
than the highest bonds.
But sometimes like in December, 2000,
the yields are almost all the same.
That's called a flat yield curve.
Other times,
like now we're in this light blue on here.
Like now the short bonds have very
small yields and the long bonds,
much higher yields. Okay, so the
last one is the 30 year bond.
So,
so it's um,
okay,
so you get the yield on every single bond.
Now what do you notice about this picture?
By the way?
They can be very different at
different time periods. So,
and in December of 2000 the interest rates
were really high. The yields were 6%.
I'm talking yields. So far we
haven't talked about interest rates.
We have to figure out what the
interest rates are. But anyway,
they're obviously going to be connected.
So the yields were very high in December,
2000 and they've got
much lower in December,
2008 and they've stayed very low.
So why are they so low now?
What got them to be so low now?
Yup.
The Fed flooded the economy with money
at wanting to drive the interest rates
down to zero.
So we're going to see very soon why the
Fed might have wanted it to do that.
But these, these money rates don't
move totally on their own. They're,
they have to do.
And we said that Irving Fisher,
we haven't described Irvin
Fischer's theory of money
and nominal interest rates,
but somehow the Fed is controlling the
nominal interest rates and it's changed.
It's changed the yield curve.
So you notice that the yield curve now,
December,
2008 was this blue one.
So the Fed in the crisis of 2008 you know,
was terrified and it dropped the
interest rate almost to zero,
virtually zero. And it's kept it there
because from December, 2008 until now,
we're at the end of, we're
almost, we're October,
2009 by September 30th,
2009 a long time has passed from this
dark blue to light blue line. And the,
and the rate has been kept fixed there.
But in the intervening time,
the long rates have started to go way up.
Now why might that be the case?
What does that suggest to anybody?
Does anybody know?
Yup.
Could, that could be one reason.
And could there be another reason?
Yup.
Okay.
So those are the two reasons.
So they somehow know that and some of
you have no idea how they could possibly
be thinking that. And so we're,
I'm going to explain why,
what information is, is there in
the different yield curves. Okay.
So the point is that every morning,
every single financial analyst wakes
up and sees these yield curves,
you know,
consults the market and sees where things
are trading and can produce a yield
curve like that. Okay. So, so
you've got a bunch of yields. Now,
what are the yields? Well, let's just
do, uh, an example here.
So I'm going to make up an example
which is very easy to compute.
So let's try this one. Okay. So suppose,
so I'm reading here at the top.
Let's just say that,
um, you've got a bunch of different
bonds, a one year bond, a two year bond,
a three year bond, a 40 year
bond, and a five year bond.
Now
each of the bonds was issued, uh,
let's say they were, you know,
often they might.
And so I'm assuming here that
they're all issued on the same day.
So they're issued with different coupons.
Let's say they were all issued today,
we'll come back at the end.
You know obviously the,
the treasury doesn't issue
new bonds every single day.
So how does this change when you arrive
on a day when they have an issue things.
But let's just keep it simple and suppose
that today the treasuries if issued
five different bonds over
these five different years,
now the treasury has to set,
how do they, what do they do?
They decide how much of these bonds
they're going to sell and they decide,
you know what coupon they're going to set.
So they set the coupon.
So let's say the coupon they set
was a dollar for the one year bond,
$2 for the two year bond,
$3 for the three year bond,
four for the four year von five for the
five year bond. It's easy to remember.
That's why I chose those numbers.
And the face value let's
say is always a hundred.
So why did they set those coupons?
Well because given how
much they want to sell,
they are picking the coupon hoping that
the price turns out to be close to the
face value.
So let's say when they actually do market
these and a supply equals demand and
aqua,
Lebron,
the prices turn out to be 100.1 a hundred
points to 100.3 100.4 and a hundred
0.5 so a hundred 0.5 as the price of the
market's paying for the five year bond.
And if the coupon is five and
they pay coupons once a year,
they actually pay you.
They may pay twice a year,
but let's say they pay once
a year for simplicity, you're
going to get five, five,
five, five and 105 the last year, if
you bought the four year coupon bond,
you'd get four, four, four a
hundred for the last year. Right?
So what, okay, so those
are the bonds. Now,
the newspapers not
telling you any of that.
So you're sort of losing that information.
Um,
so you don't actually know that
from reading the newspaper.
So then what do you
know? Uh, you know, that,
you know, the, uh, you know, the,
the yields on all these things.
Okay.
So you might hear this tells you
the yield on each of these bonds.
Okay. Now, um, yeah,
going back to where I was.
Okay.
Okay. If you, knowing the yield,
you could figure out what the price of
each of the bonds is or in fact the way
that they calculated the yield
at the newspapers reported.
How did the newspapers get the
yield? The newspaper said, well,
for the four year bond,
we're going to say that
a hundred point 400.4
equals four by one plus the four year
yield for the four year coupon bond yield
plus a four over one plus y of four
squared plus four over one plus y o four
cube plus 104 over one
plus y o for the fourth.
Okay. And then the, in this case,
because these numbers are all positive,
obviously it's monotonic. And why a four?
So the unique, why a four, which
you can use to solve this equation.
Price equals the discounted
value at that yield of, uh, the,
the, the payments. Okay. So that's
how the newspapers, the reporter,
that's how he got all the
yields to show you that graph.
He looked at the market or can call
the bank or something like that,
had a computer screen, you know,
talk to his friends on Wall Street.
He knew the price of all the bonds,
he knew the coupons of all the bonds and
then he produced the yield for all the
bonds. So the yield, as I say, it's just,
that's the word that everybody uses.
But really the information that you want
to deal with is the price and what are
the coupon actually pay.
Okay, so that's what you know,
everybody knows this every day.
The information I've given every morning,
maybe every few hours
people will update it.
They'll look at what are the coupon
bonds paying and what are the prices,
the thing that's changing, you know,
from hour to hour or the prices.
But we're taking a snapshot at the
beginning of the day and looking at the
prices.
So now we've got prices of bonds,
which I'm not call capital pies.
Pi One pi two Pi three five foreign pie
five but now what is fish or say you
should do,
what's the most important thing to do?
The most important thing to
do is find the interest rates.
So what does this got to do
with interest rates? Well,
if you modernize Fisher a little bit,
the most important thing,
fish this is,
he didn't put it this way,
but this is really what
he must have meant.
The most important thing to do
is fine the prices of the Zeros.
So Peak Pie Juan is today's money price.
Today's money price
for $1 at time one.
Hey ty two is today's money price.
$1 at time two Pi three.
Today's money price at
time three and pie five.
Okay,
today's money price at time five.
Okay. Now why do you want to find these
things? Cause once you know these things,
you'd be able to value any investment.
That original investment that we
talked about, which maybe disappeared.
This one.
Um,
it doesn't be hard anyway.
Once you have all the pies.
If tells you, you know, how do they ha ha.
If a hedge fund tells you these are the,
these are the, these are the, you know,
this is the revenue I'm going to
produce for you in the next five years.
If they tell you, if a company
says, this is more business plan,
we're going to put,
we're going to build a factory today
that's going to cost a certain amount of
money and we're going to get pro profits
in the next five years, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. If, uh, um, uh,
a new bond comes on the market and you
don't know how to price and somebody
offers you a price for it,
how do you figure out what it's worth?
All you do is you take the cashflows,
the C's that I not very cleverly erased.
You take the cash flows and
multiply them by the pies.
So the correct price p is just whatever
the cashflows you're predicting times
these pies that Fisher says what
you should really be finding.
Okay?
So nothing could be simpler if you
know now, why is this the right price?
Because if you can go in the
market and buy a dollar at time,
one for Pi of one and a dollar at
time too for Pi of two, et Cetera,
you can buy all the cashflows from this
investment project by spending this
amount of money.
So if the guy is offering you the
investment opportunity at a higher price,
it's crazy to do it.
You could have bought those cashflows
yourself by paying this price.
If he offers it to you at
a lower price than that,
then definitely you should
do it because you can, um,
you know, it's a bargain because
if you had to buy it yourself,
it would be more expensive.
In fact,
you can make an arbitrage profit if he's
offering it to you at a lower price,
you can buy it. And how do you buy
it? By selling these very promises,
c one c two CT on the market.
And if people believe you that you'll pay,
you can sell it for this price.
So you buy his project for a lower price,
you sell it for a higher price,
you make the difference.
And when it comes time
to keep your promises,
the project has given you the
cash to keep your promises.
So you lock in a profit for sure.
So if you knew the pies,
you would know for sure how to value at
any project where you knew for sure the
cashflows, knowing the pies
would tell you how to value it.
And we'll tell you whether it
was attractive or not attractive.
You just look at how high the present
value is. Okay? Any questions about that?
So we just figure out, we just need
to figure out how did the Deuce,
what the little pies are from the data
that we're going to be given and that we
are given every day by the market.
Okay?
Okay.
So I said literally Pi one is the price
you would pay today to buy a dollar
tomorrow.
Now how could you go about buying a
dollar tomorrow given that the only things
you can trade on the market are these
treasury bonds, these government bonds.
And I've told you what they pay off and
I've told you what their prices are.
So how would you go and buy a dollar
tomorrow and how much would it cost you a
dollar next year?
How would you do that?
You can trade, buy or sell any of these
treasury bonds. So, you know, I, I'm,
I in the background, I
keep saying that, uh,
we're going to have to worry
about people defaulting.
We're not quite doing it yet.
So buying a treasury bond,
you need the cash to buy it.
Selling a treasury bond means you
promise to deliver what the Treasury bond
promises and you're selling it.
You know,
your promises as good as the governments.
So if you sell it to somebody,
they'll pay you the same government price
for it. So obviously in the background,
you're going to have to do something
to convince the guy you're making the
promise to that you're
going to keep your promise.
So we're going to worry about that later.
So for now,
when I say that the market for those
treasury bonds clears that those levels,
I mean that anybody who wants to can buy
treasury bonds at those levels or can
sell them,
even if he doesn't have them at those
prices by making the promise of what the
treasury bond does. Cause we're
assuming the government and you,
everybody is just as reliable.
Everybody's going to keep their promise.
So whether it's the
treasury making the promise,
are you making the promise
of the same thing? Okay,
so how do you buy a dollar next year?
What would you do when the market with
the treasury bonds to get $1 next year?
Yup. Oh, you're not,
I'm prices and then figure out
which button.
Well,
um,
you're supposed to be telling me what
do you want to do and I want to know
exactly what to do. You can look
at those numbers. By the way,
are you all following these? I
may be. This was missing serious.
There's a one year,
a treasury bond that pays $101 next year,
the two year treasury bond pays $2 next
year than a hundred to the three year
treasury bond pays $3 the
end of the first year,
three at the end of the second year, 103
at the end of the third year, et Cetera.
Okay. And the one year and treasury bond
happens to be selling for this price.
The two year happens to
be selling for that price.
So what can I do with all these
bonds to buy a dollar next year back?
All right, go ahead. You've started
a two year bond. It's next year,
one year from now.
Bye.
I'm asking you how you're a
step ahead of me. I'm saying,
what do you do? Nevermind.
How much does it cost?
What do you do today
to get a $1 next year?
What transaction can you make today?
What purchase can you make today
to get yourself $1 next year? Yes.
Buy a one year bond.
Well that'll give me $101 next year.
I want $1 next year.
Okay.
Well exactly the point.
It's okay. Right? I take that fraction.
That's what I want you to tell me.
So
Hi.
One is going to be little pie.
One is going to be won over 101 times
the price of the one year bond cause the
one year bond is paying.
Um,
the one your bond is paying $101.
So you take one 101st of eight you'll
get $1 and whatever the price of the one
year bond is actually we know
what that is. It's a 100.1.
You know,
that's how much it costs to buy.
One of them costs a hundred
0.1 to get one over a hundred.
One of them costs Pi one.
Okay,
so this number by the way is some number.
Okay. Which actually, uh, I
of course worked out here,
happens to me 0.991 but
we'll come back to that.
Okay,
so that happens to be 0.991.
So now we know py one well,
how would you buy $1 at time
at year two in year two?
So there's a way of directly buying
$1 in year two once you know what the,
um,
how the treasury's trade.
So what I'm doing is I'm
explaining the idea of replication
replication,
a pricing that's giving me pricing
and it's going to lead to arbitrage.
They're all basically going
similar ideas here. Okay?
So what I want to do is
directly by $1 in year two.
So I could probably go to a bank and they
would actually make that trade for me.
I could just call up the bank and say,
I want $1 in year two and they tell me
pie to how much I have to pay for it.
But how are they going to
figure out, uh, what it's worth?
They're going to see how they're going
to go out and have to buy the dollar for
me.
Uh,
so they're going to go out and go to the
treasury market and what are they going
to do in the treasury market to come
up with my dollar in year or two?
They're going to replicate my purchase
of $1 with a more complicated portfolio
that they can,
but they can actually trade.
And that's how they're going to figure
out how to price my request for $1 in
year two. So what is this bank
going to do on the treasury market?
What does it have to do to get $1 for
sure in year two and nothing else.
Okay.
For it's one was mentioned
this, but they buy it to your phone
and then settle it when you're mind.
Okay. So what are they going to do? How
much of the two year bond should they buy?
Uh,
uh,
the two year bond don't,
you're not selling them,
you're talking about the two year bond.
So how much of the two year bond are
they going to buy? One, one o seconds.
That's right. That's very good.
Why is that? Because in year two,
we're talking about here too.
Now you're to the two year bond pays
102 if you got one over a hundred,
two of those,
you've got $1 in year two.
So that's Pi of to,
okay,
so which happens to be a hundred 0.2
that's how much that costs. Okay, but
is that all you need to do? I mean,
is that it?
Are you paying the right amount?
Are you paying too much
or what are you doing?
You've got to do more than just that.
Why is that?
Yeah,
close but not quite. Okay, so,
so do your reasoning before you got the,
you told me what else to do,
which you slightly miss said,
so why do you have to do anything at all?
Tell me the reason why you want to do
something else. You're right. You're,
you're on the right track. He just
slipped up a little bit. So what do you,
why do you,
why not just stop here?
Exactly. So that's exactly right.
By buying the two year treasury,
you got a 102 and period.
You know, you've got, well,
by buying this fraction of the two year,
you got just what you
want in period a too.
But you also purchased the coupon
in period one which you don't need.
So that's giving you more than you
needed to buy. You've bought extra,
so you're going to actually
be able to, to uh, the real,
the cost of getting the dollar at the
end of year two is a little bit less than
what we've written so far.
Because you bought more so far,
this is buying too much.
You bought the dollar in year two.
You also bought a little bit in year one.
You can now sell off the extra stuff
you've gotten in year one to reduce your
cost of buying that. So what should
you do in year one? So you were,
that's exactly what you were thinking.
You just didn't quite say it. Right.
So what should you do in year one?
I sell that. Okay. I sell.
Okay. So I can get to sell
to have little pie of one.
Right. Because I know how much it
costs me to buy a dollar at time one.
Now it's that number so I can see.
So I'm getting, so is that correct?
What I've written here? That's what
you said. That's not quite right. Yeah.
Okay. So this is what he meant to say.
So that's fine. You know, it's, it's so,
okay, so that's what you do. Exactly.
So everybody's following you. You,
you agree with me now. Right.
But you know, we could simplify,
we could plug in for this too, by the way.
So Pi of one, we know what that is. Yeah.
Okay.
So does everybody see what's going on
here to buy a dollar at time to you buy,
uh,
you don't get the whole to your treasury.
You buy one 102nd of the two
year treasury. So it costs
you that amount of money,
but that gives you a little
bit of extra time. One,
how much extra does it give you?
Well,
you've got $2 extra for
every two year treasury,
but you didn't buy a whole two year
treasury. You bought that fraction of it.
So it gives you this much extra,
which you now get to sell off.
So you're going to sell it
off for this price pi one.
And of course we can plug in for Pi one
by putting a 101 down here and putting a
hundred 0.1 up here.
Okay.
So that
that was pretty clear. Right? So now, um,
any questions about that?
So that's going to be some number
which I calculated a again,
which happens to be 96 2.9619999999999997
yeah.
So notice of course it's getting
cheaper to buy, you know,
how much does it cost to
buy a dollar in year one?
It's that to buy a dollar
in year two is less. Okay.
Now what about Pi three
how would we get pi three
we'll stop it by three.
How would we get pi three and then
we're going to find a very fast way of
computing all these numbers. What's
by three how would you get that? Yup.
Hi.
So the three year bond costs a hundred
0.3 but we don't need all of it.
We just need,
we don't eat all of it.
We need one over 103 units times that.
Okay.
So that's, that's our main
cost. But then what else?
Right.
Minus three over one oh three times pot.
Little Pie of too,
right?
Because we got this extra
stuff that we didn't need.
Cool.
Okay.
So He's saying minus three times
one all three of Pi of one.
Okay. Cause we didn't need that.
So is that the right answer?
It's not the right answer, but why
it's close. So what did he overlook?
So he said you buy the three year bond.
So by buying the three
or bond you're getting,
if you bought the whole three or bonding,
you get three three 103 you
only want one at the end.
So you have to divide by 103.
Now we get three over one oh three
three over one oh three one and so he's
saying we've got two
extra payments, let's, um,
sell them off. And so he saw, okay,
so he sold them off like that?
That actually that's correct.
So he sold them off.
And so this one he sold off at Pi two
and this one he sold off at Pi one.
So as you ease making use of the fact
that we've already found out this price
and this price, but actually that's
slightly okay. But what would you have to,
so we're talking about
not what you would do,
talking to the bank or we're talking about
with the banker would do and he's got
a trade in the treasury market.
So how's this guy going to do this?
The banker and the treasury market.
Now this Pi over $2 he's going to have
to hold this complicated portfolio.
He's going to, what's he
gonna do to s to, to, to uh,
okay.
He's going to have to combine the one in
the two year to do this thing and then
the one year to undo that thing.
So it's actually going to be,
so in terms of trading, if you just had
to trade treasuries, what would you do?
So this is the correct formula?
That's correct.
And we can figure out what that is.
Okay.
And so the correct formula
is 91.68 91 points.
Point nine nine one seven.
Okay.
But you see,
what you've done is,
these are the kind of fictitious things
that Irving Fisher has hildas deduce.
What you're really doing in the
market is trading the treasuries.
So here you've traded a treasury,
you bought one over a hundred,
three units of a three year treasury.
Now what else should you do?
You've got a trade treasuries.
How can you sell off the,
this amount of money in year two? You
have to sell some treasuries to do that.
So what would you sell
the two year coupon bond?
And so how much of that would you sell?
Well, this is the amount of
money you have to uh, get an,
and the two year coupon
bond delivers how much money
delivers 102.
So if you did one over a hundred second,
you would get one. So you have
to divide this by 102. Okay.
And that you multiply by the price.
Yes,
by the price, which is 0.9
sick by, uh, by the price,
which is a hundred 0.2
bay.
So there's that term,
right?
So what have we done here? We've had
to sell off this amount of money.
So how can you sell off
this amount of money?
Well by selling one over 102 year
treasuries, you're selling off a dollar,
but you don't want to sell off a dollar.
You want to say all of something smaller
than a dollar. So to that amount.
So you're selling that amount
of two year treasuries, but now,
now what do you have to do?
Now you see you've bought some one year
dollars by getting the three year coupon
bond and you sold off some but you,
but by selling the two year coupon bond,
you've made some promises in year one.
So you've got a net out all of those
things and do the right thing on the one
year coupon bond, right? So
it looks a little complicated,
but you can obviously do it by Algebra.
So everybody following,
you're not following what
the right thing to do is.
But let's just say in words
what we've done in words.
What we've done is we've said there are
things you can actually trade on the
market. Those are the treasuries,
those are our benchmarks. Securities,
let's call them benchmarks.
Now what we're interested in is some
other maybe fictitious securities or new
securities.
The price of the Zeros.
Those are the basic building blocks that
will help us evaluate the present value
of any investment.
So the reason why we know these prices
is because we can replicate them by
trading only the benchmarks,
only the treasuries.
So to get the one year zero we just buy
us the correct fraction of one year.
Treasuries do you get the two years zero?
We have to buy the correct fraction of
two year treasuries and sell the correct
fraction of one year treasuries.
And that gets us that thing.
So we've replicated the two years Ziri
zero by a portfolio consists of being
long for two year treasury and
short the one year treasury,
right?
To get the three years zero coupon,
we have to buy the three year treasury,
sell the two year treasury
and do something complicated
that we haven't quite
figured out with yet with
the one year treasury.
And that will duplicate
the three years zero.
And then we'll just fix and then we'll
just add up the cost of that portfolio
that replicates this. And that must
be the price of that thing. Okay.
So that's what we're doing.
So there are any questions about that?
Are you following this or?
Yup.
Quiet
time.
One
today is zero.
So Pi of one is what you pay at
time zero to get a dollar at time.
One Pi of two is what you paid today at
time zero you get a dollar at time too.
Okay? So knowing those little
pies, you can evaluate the,
the price of anything just by multiplying
the little pies by the cash flows in
the future.
And now the trick,
this is a trick we're going to
see over and over and over again,
the subtlety and finances that they don't
just tell you what the little pies are.
You have to figure that out yourself.
Okay?
And so how are you going to
figure out the little pies? Well,
you know that you know the treasuries,
you can trade the treasuries and
you know what those prices are.
You can see it on the market.
So by combining the treasuries
in a very clever way,
you can end up getting
the prices of all the,
the zero coupon bonds, the things
that pay just a dollar at the end.
Why are they called zero coupon bonds?
Because it's like you just get principal
at the end of $1 without any coupons in
the middle. So the, the,
the little pies are called the zero coupon
prices because the payments are just
$1, you know Pi three is the price of $1
a time three it's as if there was a bond
that paid no coupons and paid a
dollar of principal at time three.
So the little pies are the prices of
zero coupon bonds of various maturities
and those aren't really
traded directly in the market.
What's traded directly in
the market where, you know,
pieces of paper change hands
are the treasury bonds,
but everybody every day is calculating
the zero coupon prices because that's
what they need to do to evaluate
every single project that they might
conceivably do that day and decide
whether it was a good project or a bad
project. Is it worth the price
or not worth the price. Okay.
And it's done by the principal of
replication. Just as we said. Okay.
So this formula is going
to be slightly complicated.
I don't know whether
it's worth writing down.
So we've got buying the three year
treasury, the right amount of that.
Then we have to sell a certain amount
of the two year treasury. Okay.
Because we accumulated extra coupons,
but now we've also going to be able to
sell a certain amount of the one year
treasuries. And so how much is that going
to be? It's going to be some formula.
Okay. So it's going to keep track of
everything we did and get a formula here.
So I'm actually not going to bother.
I think I was going to write
down the formula of it.
It'll take three minutes to work it out
because there's a much faster way of
getting all these numbers.
But
does there is everybody with me hear how
you all understand how I could get this
number if I wanted to do the work to
get it, I'd figure out I had to sell.
You know, I could, you know,
I'd sell some of the one year and
buy back some of the two year.
I do something complicated
here. Okay. So, sorry.
I would do something with the one year
treasury here to compensate for the fact
that the three year thing I
bought is paying me coupons here.
The two year thing I sold is
reducing some of those coupons.
And so it's only the net coupon that I
can sell and on a cell that by selling
the one year treasury. Okay. So that's
how I would get the number there.
And I added the cost of doing all
those things together and I get 0.917.
So,
um,
yeah,
you're silent, but are you
following it? Who Can I? Okay.
So it's too complicated to just figure
this stuff out all the time. All right.
So instead,
there's a very fast algorithm
that you can do almost instantly.
And that's why it's such a triviality
to calculate these numbers every day.
So it's called the principle.
It's the principle of duality.
You go backwards and you say
to yourself, you know, um,
what I want is Pi one pi two Pi three,
Pi four and pie five and I've started
to figure out what the replicating puts.
So these are the prices of Zeros,
prices
of zero coupon bonds,
zero coupon bonds.
That's what I want.
Want
prices of zero coupon bonds.
I have the prices of the treasuries and
the way I'm figuring out the prices of
the zero coupon bonds is by replication.
Now,
if somebody's stupidly as
happened in 50 and 60 years ago,
fairly routinely,
if somebody was willing to trade me,
you know, to, to someone was
willing to give me a dollar, uh,
in year three and only
asked 90 cents for it,
then I would have be
able to lock in a profit.
How can I lock in a profit?
Because I would just, he,
he's willing to give this to me for a low
price of 90 cents instead of 91 cents.
So what can I do? Let's say
he's willing to, uh, he would,
he'd pay me, let's say more likely.
Let's say he'd pay me 93 cents.
Say Some guy came to me,
I'm the banker, and he says,
I'll pay you 93 cents today to
get a up dollar in year three.
In other words, for three years, zero.
Well I'd say that's wonderful.
I'll,
I'll sell them this promise and
year three of a dollar for 93 cents.
Then with that 93 cents I'll only use
91.7 of those senses and I'll go out and
buy the three years zero
and three year treasury.
I'll sell some of the two year treasury
and I'll sell a little bit more of the
one year treasury. And
by doing that and, and,
and that portfolio which I've done by
doing that will pay me exactly a dollar in
year three enabling me to
keep my promise to him,
but it will only have cost me 91.7 cents.
All of made a 1.3 cent profit for sure.
With no chance.
It's a pure arbitrage.
I made the profit of 1.3 cents with
no chance of losing any money, okay.
Because I've done all the transactions
today and all the government's going to
keep its promises.
I don't have to worry about the
government giving me the money.
And so I'll be able to turn the money over
to that guy in year, uh, in year three,
and meanwhile he's given me his 93 cents.
So if you want to do an
arbitrage and make your profit,
you have to figure out what
the replicating portfolio is.
And the replicating portfolio
also tells you the price,
but it takes a long time to figure out
what all these arbitrage replicating
portfolios are.
And maybe nobody's coming to you and
offering a stupid deal like that.
So you don't need to figure out.
So the principle of duality is you
don't need to figure out the replicating
portfolio to figure out what the Pi one
pi two Pi three Pi foreign pie five bar.
I can find those numbers now
just by clicking a button,
an XL trivially without bothering
to find the replicating portfolios.
Then if some,
you know,
bad trader comes to me and offers me 93
cents for the three years zero coupon,
then I'll figure out the replicating
portfolio and take advantage of that offer
to make a pure profit.
For sure. So I want,
I want to show you now is how to get pie
one through pie five without having to
go through this complicated calculation
and it just reasons backwards.
Okay? So please interrupt if
you're not following this logic.
So it,
you reason like this,
we don't know what [inaudible] are,
but if you did know them,
you'd be able to price the very
bonds that the market is trading.
So you'd know that a 100.1 had to equal
one oh one times Pi of one and you know
that a hundred 0.2 the
two year zero coupon bond,
whose prices 100.2 would have
to be two times Pi have two uh,
two times Pi of one plus
102 times Pi have to
right?
Because Pi of one remember is the price
you pay today for a dollar one year from
now.
$101 one year from now costs a 101 if
you knew py one this would be the price.
Okay?
If you knew py one in Pi two you could
figure out the price of the zero coupon
bond.
I mean the two year treasury bond because
$2 a time one costs two Pi one and
$102 and time to costs Pi two and then
the three years a hundred 0.3 equals
three times Pi one plus three times
Pi two plus 103 times Pi of three.
Okay, so et cetera. I know we can go down
to the last wall. Just write them all.
It doesn't take second.
Hey in the last one is a hundred 0.5
equals five times Pi one plus five by two
most five price three plus five Pi
four plus one oh five by five okay,
so you don't know the little pies but
you do know these prices because the
market tells you and you know
the payoffs of all the bonds.
Because that's just written
on there, you know, that's,
that's written on them literally.
So you can just read what the payoffs are
and you know the government's going to
keep its promise. So rather than
doing this complicated stuff,
trying to figure out the Pi's,
assume you had the pies,
and then if you have the pies, it will
tell you what the prices, everything more.
So if you guessed the wrong pies,
you'd get the wrong prices.
But basically you're solving
five equations and five unknowns.
And that's what Xcel is so good at.
It's going to start with a wild guess
of the pies and then it's gonna move
around the Pi's until you
match all these prices.
And since it's five
equations and five unknowns,
you'll hit and they're
all linearly independent.
It'll be a unique set of
pis that it'll calculate.
But that one set of pis has to be the
replicating portfolio prices because
there's only one set of pis that are
going to work and solve these equations
named the ones you got by
the replicating argument.
So we can figure out the Pi's by solving
five equations and five unknowns.
So that's what I do. So if you, right,
if you guessed the pies
one, one, one, one, one,
any questions about what I'm
doing? You're right. One one, one,
one, one you're going
to get prices. You know,
for the first one it'll just be 101 and
for the two year it'll be two times one
plus 102 times one is 104 for the
third one with all the Pi's one,
which is obviously not the right thing,
it would be three plus three plus three.
That's a hundred you know,
109 so those are bad prices.
We're trying to match what the
market says the prices are. Okay.
So all I do is I subtract
the market prices were trying
to match from the actual
prices. I look at what the error is,
what you're trying to make a zero.
Then I square the error. And then there's
always, this was adding would be error.
Some see 16 to Ge 16 I added the air.
And so I know I want to do my,
my Xcel thing and hopefully I haven't
done this, but let's, I,
you know, I got to work.
Okay,
so minimize
that,
such that by changing cells and
which are the cells I want to change,
I want to change the pies. Those are
the ones that are wrong. So I do that.
So I'm minimizing the square
to her by changing the pies.
Uh,
18 okay.
And I saw,
okay,
okay.
And I'm done it and there is the answer.
And so you notice that I got the
same prices that I told you about.
Oh four by replication,
(991) 962-1917, nine,
nine one nine, six, two,
nine one seven et, etc.
Okay, so we got the pies.
So that's step one.
All right.
So that's what every single financial
firm in the entire world does every single
morning and sometimes every single hour.
So are there any questions
about what we just did
you think you could do you have
to do this in the problem set?
Are there any questions or
anything you about this?
Okay. Now I'm going to start deducing
all kinds of surprising things from this.
I hope that you'll be surprised.
So,
but I want to make sure you've got
the concept of what we've done now.
Anybody puzzled by it?
Okay,
so somehow Fisher's Pi one pi two Pi
three Pi four Pi five are are going to be,
uh,
you know,
deducible from market to what's
going on in the markets every day.
All right, so let's ask one more
thing that's deducible. Suppose I,
I go to a bank and say,
um,
I promise to give you
a dollar in year two,
how many dollars will you
give me in year three?
What do you think the
bank's going to tell me?
Every bank will give me the same
answer. If that yield curve, you know,
given where you know, this morning and
that was this morning's yield curve.
If I ask every bank in the world,
I'll give you a dollar new year to you.
Tell me how many dollars you'll,
you know, be willing to give me.
So I'll give you today. So
what am I doing? I'm saying,
I promise today to hand over to you
a dollar in year two and you know,
I'm going to keep my promise and in
exchange I want a promise from you to give
me a certain number of
dollars in year three,
how many dollars is the bank and
offered to give me in year three?
Every bank will give the same answer.
And what would that answer be?
So the thing I'm asking is I'm asking
for what's called the forward interest
rate.
Okay? So we've got these things are
obviously very important numbers.
Those are the most important things.
Fisher would say.
Those are the prices you
used to get everything. But
now I want to say something.
Um, I'm gonna ask another important
thing, almost as important.
I want the forward rate.
So one plus I won.
Yes, you can see that. I'm glad you
pointed that. Can you see this? Okay,
the camera man told me this board
was great. But anyway. Um, so
how about one plus?
Okay.
So I'll write one plus
I won forward is um,
uh, by the way, my calling at
one plus zero or one plus one.
I clicked,
sorry.
Just want to get my notation straight.
Okay,
so let's call one plus I zero
is the one plus I t is the
uh,
number of dollars,
uh, uh, at t
plus one,
uh,
in exchange
for $1 at t.
So this is a number of
dogs, a t plus one, uh,
agreed today.
Okay?
Okay.
So we agreed today that you're going to
pay this many dollars at time t plus one
in exchange for $1 at time t.
So why this is like the interest rate
that you might pay at time t you give up a
dollar time t how much do you get at
time? T plus one, the interest rate,
but we're not there yet.
We're agreeing to it today.
So today we're agreeing to
this interest rate. Okay?
So what is the interest
rate we'd agreed to today?
So we've locked in the rate when it comes
to time t one guy's going to hand over
the dollar.
And when it comes to time t plus one
the other guy is going to give back this
many dollars. So what is the
rate we would lock in today?
It's called the period t interest rate
forward because we're locking it in today
for a forward period of time.
But it's really just the normal
time t interest rate for one year.
But we're locking it in today.
So what would we lock in today?
Okay,
what? What's that? How do we compute
that? We already know what that number is.
What is it?
Yes.
Well I put tea here. So something
like that. What's so what?
Fine.
Okay. Exactly. That's Pi
ti over Pi t plus one.
That's it. Exactly. So why is that?
Right?
So all we're doing is this forward rate.
We're exchanging time ti dollars for time.
T plus $1 at this ratio,
but where we're committing to do it today,
but today we already know what the ratio
is of time t dollars to time t plus $1.
We know that pie too is in
fact we know what it is.
Pie Two happens to be
nine 62 that's a bigger
number than Pi three.
Two from today's point of view,
a dollar time two is worth
more than a dollar a time.
Three we already know how much more a
dollar at time t two is worth than a
dollar at a time.
Three it's the ratio.
Pi Two over Pi three so that ratio is,
he says py,
two of over Pi three has to be exactly
the exchange rate that the people are
agreeing to today.
That's, that's what Pi do.
Pi Three mean and if you express it
as an interest rate, it's one plus.
The forward interest rate at
that ratio is one plus I f t.
Okay. Now why is this okay? Any questions
about that? That's the second. Uh,
Yup,
go ahead.
If the yield curve is downward sloping,
yes,
you're getting lots of money,
you give them a dollar less than a dollar.
Okay, so you've made a little mistake
and your premise, so the you could, okay,
so let's, let me, good question,
but let me phrase your question a little
differently so you'll see the answer to
it. The yield curve was, um,
almost flat in year 2000.
Okay, so new year in 2000 and you'll
turn was almost flat. In fact,
there are moments where the
yield curve seems to go down.
Okay, so what is that? Uh,
yeah.
If the yield curve goes down,
what does that mean?
Does that mean that that's like
between year six and year seven,
the year of the yield curve
went down a little bit.
Does that mean that pie
seven is less than Pi six?
Maybe, but it couldn't
really be that way. Okay.
So let me translate his
question. He's saying, look,
yield curves very often are flat.
Mostly they go up very often.
They're flat,
sometimes even start to go down.
And he said that worries me that
maybe Pi seven is less than Pi six.
Okay. But that shouldn't,
so that could never happen.
That would be crazy because that would
mean that there'd be a negative interest
rate in the future. And with money that
can never happen. You can store the money.
No one's ever going to ask
for a negative interest rate.
He could just keep the dollar and keep
it in his pocket. Okay, so why is that?
So remember Pi six equals one over one
plus the six year yield to the sixth
power and Pi seven equals one over y
plus the seven year yield to the seventh
power.
So it could be that why seven is
less than y six as it is there.
And yet pi seven is still small.
Could couldn't be that why seven is
less than y six as it is over there.
But because you're taking this to the
seventh power and this to the sixth power,
you still have pi seven less than by six.
So just because the yield curve is
downward sloping doesn't mean that the pis
are going down, the pis could never go
down. The pies are always going to go up.
Okay, so excellent question.
Any other questions?
Okay,
so we could get the eyes.
Now the eyes will typically be going up.
Suppose the yield curve is going up.
By the way,
will the eyes be going up faster
or slower than the then the,
um,
then the yields?
Yeah. If this is the yield curve
and I calculate the forwards,
do you think the Ford's will be going
up faster or less fast than the yields?
All right,
well let's do it in the example.
So let's just go back to our
example that we were doing.
MMM.
Yield curves spreadsheet.
Okay, so maybe I did it here.
Hopefully I'm solved at all. Okay, so
here we got the uh, the actual pies.
You see the pies are always
declining, okay? And if we,
uh,
now look at the yield curve,
you can figure out the yield.
How can you figure out the yield?
Because you solve that formula.
We gave it the very beginning.
You take the price of the, I guess
I've erased it now, you know,
okay. You know what the price is to
figure out the yield on the three year,
we just plug in one plus y of three,
one plus y of three squared.
One over one plus y are three squared,
one over one plus y of three cubed.
And that gives us the yield. Remember,
that's how the newspaper
reporter figuring out the yields.
So I figured out the yields
in the spreadsheet. Okay,
down here and here are the yields. So this
is what would appear in the newspaper.
The one year yield is a little under 1%
the two year yield is a little under 2%
the three years a little under 3% the
four years a little under 4% and the five
here's a little under four
under 5% those are the yields.
So what if we did the forwards,
the forage?
Remember just the ratios of these pies.
What are the forwards?
They're down here.
So what do they do?
Sorry, I don't know how I did that,
but here are the forwards over here.
So the forwards have gone up
much faster than the yields.
Hey,
they went from 0.08% which is the same
as that one to 2.9 which is bigger than
2.8 to five which is way more than 3.8
to 7.2 just way more than that to 9.6
which is way more than that.
So the forwards went up
much faster than the yields.
So why is that?
Obviously gonna be the case whenever
the yield curve is upward sloping.
So if we go back to our picture here,
mmm.
We go back to our picture. If the
yield curve, we're completely flat.
What do you think the
forward yields were being?
This is just common sense just to see
if you have any idea what's going on.
If you think about batting averages and
how somebody is average changes each
time he bats.
If the yield curve is flat,
like in 2006 the forwards are
going to basically be flat.
But if the yield curve is upward sloping
than the forward yields are going to go
up much faster.
So why is that?
Okay.
Well remember
the yields that you know,
okay,
when you do a five year coupon bond,
you're discounting all the cashflows,
the previous four cash flows, you're
using the same yield to discount them all.
So if you go from year four to year five,
okay.
And you have to raise the yield
a lot. It means, you know,
like if you're a batter
and your average goes up,
it means the last thing you did was better
than the average of what you've done
before. So it's going to be
even higher. You know, if you,
if your average was 300 and then you
played a series against the red sox and
which you did very well and your average
one up to three 20 in that series
against the Red Sox,
you obviously did even better than three
20 because you had to average what you
did then with what your previous 300 to
get three 20 so if the average sort of
is going up, remember the yield is
the same thing over the whole history.
If when you take a longer history,
the average has gone up.
It must mean that the most recent
thing went up really much more. Okay.
So the four year yield
is sort of averaging,
the payoffs are the first four years,
the five year yields averaging it
over five years. So if that yield,
the five year yield has gone up,
what happened in the fifth year?
It must have gone up a lot to bring
the long run average up. Okay?
So that's why the the yield curve
is going to go up much faster. Okay,
so we know now to summarize,
everybody can look at these pictures
every single day from these pictures.
They can deduce the pies.
That's the crucial variable and
the whole economy of the pis.
But a second crucial variable
is the forward yields.
The one plus I F's,
which you can just get by the pies.
Now why are the oneplus
I F's so important.
We know the pies are critical because
they evaluate every project by multiplying
the cashflows by the pies.
Why are the forwards so important?
The forwards are so important
because suppose you believed that.
So the forwards, let's go back
to what we got. Okay, so let's,
uh, just look at the number of the
numbers here. Here are the forwards.
Remember down here? Okay.
Suppose I said to you,
you tell me you don't know
anything about the economy maybe,
but you can read the newspapers and do
mathematics like we've just been doing.
What do you guessed? The interest
rate's going to be in year two.
So this is the zero year for
the one year for the two year,
for the three or four in
the four year forward.
If I say near to what do you
think the interest guess,
what you think the interest rate's
going to be, what would you guess?
Yeah,
sure.
Yes.
Right.
I could do this real interest rate by
doing it for tips official would say do
that trouble is that are not traded
as they re coming more and more freely
traded in the market.
They used to be traded,
very people didn't want to trade them.
So my classmate,
Larry Summers, uh, introduced
tips, uh, treasury,
treasury inflation protected
securities and he, you know,
announced this was a fantastic idea and
it's going to change radically the whole
markets and the,
nobody traded them and they,
they offered astronomical,
uh, interest rates,
real interest rates to get anyone to
buy them. And so they were nicknamed,
it's really bad on camera, but their
nickname became totally illiquid pieces.
And so that was so,
so the market has not used the
tips to do most of its pricing.
It uses the treasury bonds,
but yes,
Fisher would say if the tips were
reliable market, you would uh,
use the tips to get
the real interest rate.
And that's really what you should
care about is the real interest rate,
not the nominal interest rate,
but we're using the treasury's here
to get the nominal interest rate.
However you've now just dodged
my question. My question was,
if I asked you to predict on the basis
of the yield curve in this example,
and what we've been able to do is what
would you predict the interest rate was
going to turn out to be two years
from now? The one year interest rate,
what would you predict?
Okay,
yeah.
Which forward right?
Neck
year two and year two.
What do you think the interest rate
will be between year two and year three?
It's today and we're asking what do you
predict the market rate of interest will
be in year two between
year two and year three.
Okay.
Okay. And I too have happens
to be right here are 5% okay,
so that's the forward.
So 5% you'd predict.
Okay.
So let me refine that a little bit.
If the world were one of total certainty,
so everybody trading today had a perfect
forecast of what was going to happen in
the future,
then of course the forward rates in the
market today would have to be exactly
equal to the Ford interest rate.
Because suppose that you knew for sure
the interest rate was going to be 4% in
year two,
how could the market to a 5% forward?
That means that some
guy is promising today,
I'll give you a dollar in year.
You give me a dollar in year two and
I'll give you a dollar five in year three
and we're agreeing to that deal.
But that's a ludicrous thing for him
to do because when he got to year two,
I see you're a two. Right? When he
got to year two, he could simply,
if he knew for sure what was going to
happen in the future and that the rate was
going to be, um, 4% he would just, uh,
I said it backwards.
What I need,
it's opposing knew for sure the right
was going to be 6% he would be a uh,
oh yeah. If he knew for sure the right
was only going to be 4% he'd be a fool for
promising to give the guy 5% today because
in the future when he got the dollar,
what would he do with it?
Put it in the bank and get it all or
for next year that wouldn't cover his
promise, he'd be screwed. Okay.
So if he knows for sure that the rate
two years from now is going to be 4% the
Ford price right.
Would also have to be 4%
so to say it backwards,
if you assume everybody knows for sure
what's going to happen in the future than
the Ford rates had had bet
would be exactly equal to
what everyone is expecting
to happen in the future.
To say it slightly differently if you
happen to be the one ignoramus in the
world who didn't know what's
going to happen in the future,
but you knew that everybody else who was
trading in the market did know what was
going to happen in the future and you
saw our forward rate of 5% then you could
deduce,
even though you were an ignoramus,
that actually two years from now the
interest rate was going to be 5% okay?
So it's just what you said,
but just said a little bit more precisely.
We're assuming here perfect
certainty about what's going on.
We're assuming the traders who trade
today all are completely convinced of
what's going to happen in the future.
Okay,
so let's go back to our picture now.
Um,
the picture of the zero yield curve.
So what do you think
this blue curve means?
What are the traders convinced
is going to happen in the future?
Assuming the traders. So W, W,
w the second half of the course is
going to be dealing with uncertainty.
We're now assuming like Irving Fisher,
that everybody trading today has no
doubt about what's going to happen in the
future. So what is, what
do we think the, uh,
what do you think these traders
think about these prices?
What about the interest rates?
We're now in the world today.
This was September 30th. It's
today. That's this curve.
What do you think traders,
what does this curve me
making the assumption that
traders today are convinced
about what's going to happen
next, you know, in the
future, 10 years, in 30 years,
what do we know that they
are convinced of? Yup.
That interest rates are
gonna go up and go up a lot.
They're not just going to go up to 4%
because that's the form that's the,
you know, the 30 year yield,
they're going to go up the,
the foreign rates are going
up much faster than that.
So we could have what they think.
So they think rates are gonna
go way up in the future. Okay.
Much higher than that because
you're starting so low,
so you're going to have staying low for
a while. So the rates have to go up,
the Ford rates really sharply
to pull the average that high.
So people are convinced that rates
are gonna go up in the future.
That's what that tells you. And why
would they be convinced to that? Well,
for the two reasons that
you gave at the beginning,
one of you said the market is
going to get more productive.
Irving Fisher has already told us that
when the market gets more productive,
you know, you're more optimistic
about what's going to happen later.
The real interest rate goes up.
And if the,
if inflation's constant and
the real interest rate goes up,
the nominal interest rate goes up.
The other possibility is that the
real interest rate stays the same,
but there's inflation in the future.
The real interest rate plus the
inflation is the nominal interest rate.
That's another explanation for why people
might expect the nominal interest rate
to go up. Okay. So you know that, uh,
the market is predicting rates going
up and the two obvious explanations
according to Fisher is that ease of the
inflation is going to go up or the real
rate is going to go up. And why
might the real rate go up? Well,
there are a bunch of reasons but most
likely because productivity is going up.
Okay. So I got one more
surprising conclusion to end this.
Okay.
So if you were certain about
the future and you had a,
uh,
you had a five year,
you took the five year coupon bond,
could you tell me what the price of the
five year coupon bond was going to be
next year?
How would you figure that out?
Assume that everybody is convinced that
the five year coupon bond, that the,
that they, they know the future for
sure. So therefore from the zero curve,
I erased my graph.
This is the last questions are,
I'll let you go as soon
as you answer this,
you need to answer this
to do the problem set. Um,
uh, oh, wrong graph. Sorry. Okay.
It's only take one second to answer this.
Okay.
I'm telling you now that this is what
everybody's looking at in the morning.
Okay. These numbers, they're getting all
the forward rates and stuff like that.
They're making all the deductions we made.
Now,
if you suppose that those
people are convinced,
they don't have any doubt about what's
going to happen in the future because
they don't have any doubt about
what's going to happen in the future,
you can infer from these prices
what they think about the future.
So the question is,
can you infer what the price
of the five year treasury,
which is now 100.5 that five year bond
is a hundred 0.5 next year it'll only be
a four year bond. Do we know what
its price is going to be next year?
Yup,
Yup.
By what Pi's that you?
Just
those pies,
but those pies or something slightly
different from those places going to be in
here later.
Remember?
And what would that,
how would you get that?
Yup.
Okay. So what you both said is
absolutely correct, unfortunately,
where two minutes, uh, w we're ending now.
So let me just end by saying in the
problem set, that's exactly the question.
What is the five year coupon
going to be priced next year?
If there's worlds of certainty,
you're going to know what all the
interest rates are in the future,
and if you know what all the
obviously Fisher tells you, you can
figure out what the prices, however,
to get the exact formula
would take a few minutes.
And I unfortunately am
a few minutes behind.
So you're going to have to figure
out what the right formula is,
but it's what he said and
what you were getting to.